Welcome to the show.
I am back from my emergency appendectomy,
which I will [inaudible]
talk about more, um, a little bit later, but
let's get into the news.
If you somehow believed that the Ukraine whistleblower
is just the total liar or a plant, someone
that can't be trusted, even though Donald
Trump has already confirmed a whole bunch
of what the whistleblower said, there's now
a second whistleblower that is in the process
of coming forward in a world where Donald
Trump wants us to think everything is fine.
We have yet another set of blockbuster allegations
potentially coming forward from another whistleblower
related to Ukraine and understand that the
second whistle blower is also an intelligence
official and has as far as we know right now,
firsthand knowledge of the Ukraine fiasco
involving Donald Trump.
Now, how far we've fallen that in the past
we'd say, Oh, a whistleblower from inside
the Intel community.
This is someone we should take seriously.
In the Trump era, one of the most maligned
areas has been the intelligence community
where the president has successfully primed
his defenders not to believe anything we hear
from the intelligence community.
Now there's an important point to make here
before we continue.
The American intelligence community has done
many bad things in the past and mostly they
have been things Republicans have liked.
Importantly, but that's an aside right now.
This is not about defending the Intel community
as a political apparatus.
Lots of right-wingers, even some on the left
say we should hate the Intel community because
it's been terrible for decades and when you
allow the intelligence community some kind
of elevated status to tell us who is behaving
okay and who is not, you are essentially giving
over political policy to spies and that's
not something we want to do.
Now, there are lots of that that make sense.
There are many political disagreements to
be had with the intelligence community's actions
in the past CIA in Latin America.
I mean I don't even need to do the list, but
this is about attacking the credibility of
individuals and the work that they do, which
is mostly motivated by wanting to do the right
thing at the individual level, which gets
us back to our story because there may even
be more than two whistleblowers at this point.
Check this out.
This is a tweet from Andrew because who represents
whistleblowers from the intelligence who said
intelligence community whistleblower update.
I can confirm that my firm and my team represent
multiple whistleblowers in connection to the
underlying August, 1220 19 disclosure to the
intelligence community inspector general.
No further comment at this time.
Multiple whistleblowers could be two, could
be more.
Now the president immediately writing this
off as the actions of the deep state.
The president of the United States is no longer
even pretending to be anything other than
a blatant conspiracy theorist tweeting quote,
the first so-called secondhand information
whistleblower got my phone conversation almost
completely wrong.
Not true by the way.
So now word is they are going to the bench
and another whistleblower is coming in from
the deep state.
Also with second hand info, meet with shifty,
keep them coming.
Now Trump mentions shifty, which is his nickname
for Adam Schiff, head of the house intelligence
committee, and this is the new attack strategy
from Donald Trump.
The first strategy was the deny, deny, deny.
That didn't work.
Then the strategy became well say that there
was nothing wrong that happened even though
you did talk about Joe Biden and most of the
material details that we got are actually
accurate even by your own admission.
Say everything was fine.
Now it's well they are all left wing democratic,
deep state plants controlled by Adam Schiff
and Trump's attorney, Rudy Giuliani, who himself
by the way, should be a target of these investigations
tweeting very much on the same page.
Quote, surprise, Democrat lawyer has other
secret sources.
Swamp media will corruptly fail to point out
it means nothing.
Now that conversation is public, no money,
no quid pro quo.
Unlike Biden helping sun make millions from
Ukrainian crook orchestrated Dem campaign
like kavanah.
Listen, these people are not well, okay, these
are truly sick people and we can do political
analyses up and down every single day.
But the political analysis fall short because
in a sense a political analysis assumes that
we are dealing with well people, which we
are not.
We are now going to get a chance to see just
how blind and bamboozled Donald Trump supporters
are.
And here's the big story.
It started with one whistleblower on Ukraine,
one on the IRS, which you may not even have
heard about.
We now have a second one on Ukraine, all within
two weeks.
Just imagine how many pent up potential whistleblowers
there are who have seen incredible illegal
things the Trumpists are doubling down on.
This is a democratic hit job.
It's all fake.
And we showed you the transcript.
Of course, the transcript is only a portion
of the call and is already terrible for them
and was already reportedly a precondition
of Ukraine investigating Biden and promising
this deliverable.
So what the Trumpists have as their strongest
defense is to pretend that the transcript
is exculpatory when in fact it is a damning
piece of evidence.
And once again, imagine what we will know
in just another week